la presidenta del sinn fein hace campaña
en el oeste católico de belfast aquí
muchos esperan que esta elección sea un
hito histórico desde hace un siglo e
irlanda del norte ha estado dominada por
representantes electos fieles a la
corona británica
[Música]
el sinn fein tiene la oportunidad de
convertirse en el partido principal pero
también de tomar el puesto de primer
ministro
esto significa que en términos de
historia contemporánea ha cambiado la
política en irlanda la sociedad es más
abierta y más progresista pero también
estamos avanzando en la ruta de la
reunificación y
en el fin de la división un siglo
después
avanzamos hacia la unificación de
irlanda
después de 35 años de conflicto la gran
mayoría de norirlandeses aceptó los
términos del acuerdo de paz firmado en
1998 ser irlandés o ser británico los
problemas de identidad dejaron de ser
una preocupación para los jóvenes
votantes hasta que él preside- revivió
el debate
estoy 100% a favor de una irlanda unida
queremos unirnos a europa queremos
viajar
hay que verlo así si queremos ser parte
de europa esta es la manera de hacerlo
[Música]
durante la campaña se organizaron
reuniones para expresar la oposición al
famoso protocolo del acuerdo británico
del brics y ese protocolo creó una
frontera comercial entre gran bretaña e
irlanda del norte
el jefe del principal partido unionista
el pp es un ferviente partidario del
preso
no podemos avanzar sin que los sionistas
lo acepten
y eso significa que no haya protocolo
no toleramos el protector
mientras el protocolo se mantenga el dvd
quiere bloquear la restauración de la
asamblea de irlanda del norte suspendida
a comienzos del año
el protocolo ha disuelto en nuestra
relación con el resto del reino en el
deterioro de la estabilidad política en
irlanda del norte dañan nuestra economía
aumenta el costo de la vida porque hace
venir los productos desde gran bretaña
es mucho más caro
por eso debemos reemplazar el protocolo
por acuerdos que respeten el lugar de
irlanda del norte- dentro del reino
unido
con pífanos y tambores
el jefe del de upper reitera los viejos
eslóganes identitarios esperando agrupar
a los votantes unionistas bajo la union
jack otra agrupación con los mismos
colores de la misma bandera aquí en
saint field una comerciante se queja por
el impacto del protocolo para su negocio
no más protocolos sin importar las
consecuencias
berlín y dirige este vivero desde hace
más de 30 años desde que el reino unido
se salió de la unión europea sus
proveedores ingleses se niegan a hacer
entregas en irlanda del norte por los
gastos de exportación hacia una región
que se quedó en el mercado único
estas plantas alpinas normalmente las
comprábamos en inglaterra pero dejamos
de hacerlo desde que se aplica el
protocolo
les envié un correo para que me las
mandarán y me dijeron que
ahora veces está obligada a comprarle
estas rosas a un intermediario en la
república de irlanda ellos las reciben
del mismo proveedor cambian las macetas
y nos las revenden en irlanda del norte
para ver el protocolo es también una
cuestión de identidad
como ciudadana británica me siento a
esta edad y mi propio país en el oeste
católico de belfast el análisis del
problema es diferente los problemas que
afectan a la cadena de abastecimiento
fueron creados por el prix y no por el
protocolo el protocolo es la respuesta
al menos en parte para las dificultades
del break si es
en la costa norte de entrimo este
mayorista importa productos alimentarios
de gran bretaña para venderlos en la
isla de irlanda el presidio afectó
directamente pero para el empresario lo
más frustrante es precisamente que en
cada elección los temas comerciales se
convierten en una cuestión identitaria
el protocolo podría tener beneficios a
largo plazo si se encontrara una
solución razonable para el control de
las mercancías como entendemos el hecho
de que irlanda sea una isla como podemos
comerciar más fácilmente aquí y también
con gran bretaña esos son los problemas
concretos de los que deberíamos estar
hablando más que volver sobre los mismos
temas de siempre en cada campaña
electoral
después del voto los ciudadanos esperan
que los funcionarios electos conformen
un gobierno pero aquí nada es menos
seguro una vez más el futuro de la
asamblea de irlanda del norte está
puesto en duda